you can have dinner with anybody dead or  alive you can't say trump you can't well  you are trump but you can't say your  father i've already had dinner with him  plenty of times how about jesus jesus  okay so jesus is who eric if he could  pick anybody to have dinner with he  would have dinner with jesus now we all  know this is not a religious family  trump didn't go to church  his kids didn't go to church this is a  character they've developed since  entering republican politics but what  gives it away  is this next part take a listen good  answer that'd be a good one right what  would you ask them oh god  did you envision this happening to the  united states of america  did you ever envision a person as  incompetent as joe biden running the  united states of america how in the  world did this happen right you can tell  how deeply spiritual he is from the  question he would ask jesus